for the best performance by an actress
in the supporting role the nominees are
Goldie horn in Cactus Flower Diane
Cannon in Bob and Carol and Ted and
Alice Katherine Burns in last summer
Sylvia miles in Midnight Cowboy and
Susanna York and They Shoot Horses Don't
They never get these things
open the winner is Goldie
h
[Applause]
[Music]
as you see Raquel welz will accept for
goalie hor who cannot be here thank you
well I'm it's a pleasure to accept this
award for her she couldn't be here
because she's in London filming but I
know she would want to thank uh all her
co-stars um Walter mathau and ingred
Bergman her director Jean saaks and Mike
frankovich and I think it's wonderful
for her thank you